hey youtubers it's Charlie so really
awesome stuff we have our Deathstroke in
the DC Universe there's also like this
Justice League team up to stand for this
political cause so I'm gonna play this
Justice League clip first then I'm gonna
play this audio interview with Joe
Manganiello there's just absolutely
hilarious it was recorded in 2013 so
just keep in mind what's happening today
because that was done before they made
Batman V Superman but here's that
Justice League clip hey I'm Ben Affleck
I'm an official I'm Jason Momoa and I'm
Ezra Miller and as a gang of earth
defenders we want to send a big shout
out to be a shitty shot Cohen and those
who stand with them in opposing the
Dakota access pipeline to get involved
with this movement go to the sacred
stone camp org thank you so the cool
thing here Joe Manganiello is like this
huge comic book fan he tells this
hilarious story about how he stole comic
like he was dirt poor like everybody is
at a certain point in their life when he
was really young then he became really
famous so he felt really bad about
stealing all these comics from this
store owner so like after he'd become
famous he took back this giant box of
stuff that he stole and was like here
you go brah sorry for stealing all this
stuff when I was younger in the store
owner was just like I don't I don't
understand what's going on here it is
really funny gonna let you know like he
is a cool dude somebody who would feel
so remorseful about something they did
as a child and go back to try and make
it right like look here's all this stuff
that I stole from you
so he lives by code just like
Deathstroke only it's not like Joe
Manganiello is walking around
assassinating people on contract so I'm
gonna play the audio from this interview
here it's actually really cool just
listening to him talk about his history
with comic books so here we go
you were swiping comic books from your
local we found out on the TV show yeah
yeah just avid comic book reader and I
thought that you know asking my dad for
the money to buy all these comics for
how fast I read them that was never
gonna fly so and I just didn't even want
to hear it I didn't want to see the face
he was gonna make when I asked him for
more money to go buy books and comic
books so I just turned a crime
at a very very young age that it's
scoping comic book stores out and
looking for the sightlines behind the
register and then how to not be seen and
then I'd wear pants with like the
elastic waistband yeah you know and so
I'll do a video recreation here really
thick frame glasses we need some
parachute pants with elastic band we
just have those anyway we should you
should bring I don't think we need them
for that we just happen we just just say
that you had classes or you just put him
on as a disguise on and like blind like
I wear context and I'm without them I am
I am blind
yeah I'm gonna do it be the reverse of
Superman to when he wakes up for the
first kicked out of him at that
[Music]
bikers they were probably somewhere to
last really did yeah but then he went
back you know let's see what what that
last scene should have been of course
it's Superman so he's not gonna but he'd
really should have just ripped that guy
lymph limb from limb and then just
spread the guy's limbs all over the
globe that we know much more interesting
yeah just him in the back alley
yeah trash dumpster holding like an arm
and a leg felt so good you know you've
got to be in a superhero movie sooner or
later once yeah well I used to draw all
I wanted to be a comic book artist when
I was a kid I just I drew compulsively
like almost like okay kid like what the
hell is wrong with you and there were
always pictures of these monsters
ripping limbs off of human beings and
entrails and you know eating that you
know my father saw the pictures of these
crazy monsters and the Stephen King
books and thought my kids are
psycho so he like hid all the books yeah
and then I think that really led me to
crime so it was like okay let's go steal
some more and read them you know so it
was kind of like this this secret you
know gorilla thing I had going on for
sci-fi and fantasy and and and so when
acting happened I think in my mind it
was it was really about you have a
chance to play a superhero like let's
take the little kid and let's hit the
Jim really hard and try to look like
that comic book and then let's see what
happens the nerd drove the jock kind of
yeah it was like the nerdy kid was like
come on man we got to make this look
right and go to drama school so you do
when you you know you can work with
these great directors and do it right
and not do a shitty superhero movie
because there's nothing worse than
shitty superhero I mean it's like
literally there is nothing worse I mean
my top five all-time worst movies are
probably Supergirl movies gone bad yeah
I mean it's just it hurts me to watch
them and makes me angry and I never you
know I wanted to make good ones you have
you ever thought about doing a comic
book if you want to yeah there's one I
grew up with there's one I actually when
I went to return all those comic books
at I stole oh that's right okay so
quickly 14 years later Rick Lee tell
that story just in case people didn't
see it i jus i just i rob these stores
you know blind like just just you know
without a thought and anything I could
get and I remember you know I remember
pulling I think I got you know I got the
comics that her and the really valuable
ones that are in back of oh wow I'm a
wall like somehow I had those like I had
like number ones and number twos it's
very good yeah I got good at it
and so 14 years later they were still at
my mom's house and I was going through
this period of like let's let's try to
be an adult and clean up all this stuff
and you know and so I found them in my
mom's closet and I called up the store
and they were still there and I went and
returned them to the owner who was still
at the store 14 years later and like
mall security came over and we were
talking about this yeah yeah on the
Nerdist show and like mall security came
over was like what's going on here
excited huge big and it was all the you
know the great stuff at that time was
that you know the Frank Miller Wolverine
in Japan and I had the McFarlane
spider-man's like all of them and I had
kind of had like you know all the
Punisher Sicilian saga and I mean all
that like this really kind of those
Golden Age like awesome ghost ghost
rider number two is this great stuff and
I wouldn't return them all and the owner
you know look down and went you know
these are these are old man I
know I did you know they're yours they
belong to you anyone what are you
kidding me yeah and he goes okay
you're absolved weightless
okay and the mall security guy looked at
me and just like raises eyebrows in
shrug then I was like ah I'm out of here
I said oh by the way there's one comic
I'm keeping I'm gonna give you the money
for it and I paid him for this one and I
kept it no and that's the one that I
want to make do you do you not want to
say what it is because you want to you
know what anyone else no one's done it
so really cool listening to him talk
about what a super fan he is how he'd
like to do comics I'd like to be in a
comic book movie but they didn't say a
whole bunch about the casting
announcement they just said that he's
going to be Deathstroke in the DC
extended universe so primarily going to
be a Batman movie character but I'm
expecting him to be teased in Justice
League in a small way just because it's
such a big movie it makes sense that
they would try to tag him in there
somewhere but whatever's going on in
Justice League it sounds like they've
been retuning that movie big time since
Batman vs Superman
Geoff Johns just went on and did this
big interview where he explained how
they were dealing with some of the
critical blowback how they were dressing
it how they're trying to be hopeful with
the previous position of the studio was
the way that that's different now how
they've kind of sped up the fun stuff in
the Justice League movie they're like
well we were gonna get to this
eventually but since then we've really
sped it up so they're getting to the
good stuff just a little bit faster but
just to explain what this Justice League
team-up promo is for it's basically a
call to action against the proposed
Dakota access pipeline which is an oil
pipeline that's gonna run across a bunch
of states so the worry is is that
because oil pipelines have a history of
breaking it poisons the earth it causes
lots of environmental damage they want
to prevent this so that's what you're
speaking out against if you're really
interested in supporting this you can go
to the website that they list at the end
of that but that is a real-world thing
it's just apropos is just appropriate
that the Justice League is forming to
save the earth in the movies they're
trying to save the earth in real life
too I think it's really cool they're
trying to be proactive in real life but
let me know in the comments what do you
think about Joe Manganiello Deathstroke
he was actually you know in related DC
News David Ayer who did Suicide Squad
directed
be called sabotage with Arnold
Schwarzenegger Joe Manganiello just
happened to be in that that movie also
starred Shia LaBeouf fun story David
Ayer brought him in to meet for Suicide
Squad was like hey you know maybe maybe
Shia LaBeouf should be in Suicide Squad
but the studio Warner Brothers was like
look this is a really big financial bet
for us and you're a great actor and all
but nah now that's paraphrasing Shia
LaBeouf like he's getting ready for this
film festival so he was just doing
interviews saying yeah I went in to meet
on Suicide Squad they're like you're
great actor but you are just way too
crazy for us so you can just try to
imagine what role Shia LaBeouf was gonna
play probably not the Joker because the
Joker is supposed to be crazy so I don't
think Warner Brothers would have blocked
that casting had they wanted him for a
crazier role maybe it was like Captain
Boomerang or something like that who
knows how ever went down it's probably
better that he was not in the movie but
if you guys didn't know there's a new
round of the DC giveaway that's going on
now I'm just giving a copy of the flash
season 2 blu-ray away all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so what's gonna
happen next is is they just posted the
first behind-the-scenes image of Thanos
on the set of Avengers infinity war and
the funny thing is is that Josh Brolin's
mocap suit is purple just like Thanos
it's perfect it's gonna be so much fun
so we'll do a video for that next cuz
they've actually started to shoot that
movie they're doing that right now as we
speak while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my flash
season 3 trailer video that I just
posted and you can click here to learn
more about Savatage backstory from the
comics thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight